my mother wanted a doll's house
he worked on it for 10 years
it was very complicated
they looked all over europe for
furnishings and fittings
steve's the optimum poor man
the doll's house tommy mistender's
parents made in the 1970s and 80s has
three stories and 13 rooms
they also made a lot of the furniture
they travel to many countries to find
accessories for the doll's house
the wallpaper for instance comes from
britain
you can't buy a doll's house like this
ready made in a shop
you've got to furnish it step by step
i think they based it on a 1920s manor
house
the doll's house is two meters tall and
a meter wide
tommy mistander hasn't changed anything
in it
it's all just the way his parents
furnished it
and he loves to show it off
the intricacy of the detail tends to
move a lot of women to tears
no matter how old they are it always
takes them back to their childhood
but now 62 year old tomi mistander has
decided to sell the house at a price of
about 10 000 euros
he keeps the doll's house at home in
mora a town in central sweden
he wishes he didn't have to let go of
this family heirloom but he has no
choice
i need the money
my mother's dead
my stepfather's still alive
they told me back then i should take it
over so now it's here
i still like having it with me
even though i'm an old man
thank you very much bye bye